it's good to see you buddy it's good to
see you too harlot time fall two ads the
first single-player campaign to the
franchise it's densely packed with
polished parkour level design intense
tide and shootouts breathtaking set
pieces it's a memorable campaign to say
the least but some might argue it's
short roughly four hours short on
regular difficulty
hence the point of this video if you are
experienced with first-person shooters
you should 100% play this campaign on
master difficulty even if master is too
much for you you can tone it down to
hard regardless you're raising the
difficulty not to lengthen the campaign
but in many ways strengthen its
enjoyability the game's campaign is
extremely well paced after finishing a
chaotic firefight you'll find yourself
parkouring through a lush wilderness
sure you can absorb and explore any of
the sights regardless of difficulty but
playing on master strengthens the
purpose of exploration there are hidden
weapon caches practically every level is
loaded with rare weapons and when times
are tough
you'll strive to find these top the
railing parkour up these random pipes up
top you'll find an EPG not to mention as
you find a need to explore you'll even
find helmet collectibles which is a plus
however if this is your first run at the
story don't burn yourself out on
searching these helmets and stashes flow
with the pacing if the radio chatter
tells you to keep moving do so
as you tackle pilot shootouts throughout
the game on master you'll find them to
be tough your health is low so low that
even a grunt can take you out with one
melee hit you'll be dying a lot and
that's typically due to one fact don't
stop moving
this isn't your typical shoot and take
cover shooter on regular you might be
able to get away with this but on master
it's a lot different comboing parkour
wall runs gives you speed and feed makes
you harder to hit the game even reminds
you of this you'll find your cloaking
ability to be more precious only using
it to leap across open areas or for
retreating you'll treat enemies
differently to stalkers Reapers and
especially tick mines are relentless
forcing you once again to never stop
moving it becomes imperative to combo
cloak and wall run in order to flank
shielded IMC soldiers and turrets
playing on master requires you to take
it one step further discovering new ways
to combo parkour map design weapons and
gadgets you'll find yourself becoming
even more creative in order to survive
the Titan battles and occasionally boss
fights can be underwhelming on regular
as the game progresses you're able to
switch between load ads on the fly
allowing you to confront enemies however
you please picking your favorite loadout
is fine however if you're sticking to
just your go-to you're missing out on
what the feature is really all about the
Titans in titanfall 2 are vastly
different and each one treats the other
differently playing on master forces you
to predict and dissect the Titan
scenario at hand say you're sniping as
North Star and a ronin dashes up into
your grill your star has practically no
defense if you want to switch to a Ronin
or Titan with stronger defensive
capabilities you're toast
and the same goes for boss fights given
the Titan bosses abilities you'll find
yourself switching loadouts not based on
preference but because of situational
awareness
again at any point you can lower the
difficulty in titanfall 2's campaign so
there really isn't much harm here in my
experience raising the difficulty
brought out more of the uniqueness with
titanfall 2 s campaign offering a
significantly better experience so if
you decide to play the campaign give
master a shot thanks for watching and
for more titanfall 2 coverage stay tuned
to game spot
[Music]